jetzt habe ich eine ak meine lieben
freunde ich kann
hallo leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge von minecraft galaxy
heute mal komplett alleine ohne jemand
anderem dabei in den letzten folgen das
ist meine erste folge in der ich jetzt
ganz alleine aufnehme bin hier glaube
ich bin ich in wharf ich bin im orf- es
ist kein anderer auf dem server ich geh
mal ganz kurz kennen und ich suche ja
schon die ganze zeit nach irgendwelchen
wüsten weil ich diese blöden kakteen wir
endlich mal machen wollte als ich wollte
man dieses kakteen pulver machen und
dadurch dass ich mir dann dies kakteen
pulver gemacht habe kann ich mir dann
was das denn ich falls ich werde mich
hier liebt aber irgendwer hat mir eine
weapons box gebastelt weil ich die ganze
zeit meinte ich finde keine wüsten hier
guckt euch mal eine karte an
ich bin ja schon so behindert in diese
richtung geflogen diese da war nix ich
werde in dieser folge noch jeden
geflogen war total hin zu fliegen
aber hey schreibt mir das mal werd mir
deine weapons box gemacht wie geil ist
das denn und da jetzt diese weapons box
haben was eigentlich mein plan war ich
konnte das ja nicht selig die gucke bald
jemanden der bkm anderen eigentlich in
die galaxy sondern versucht mein eigenes
ding so ein bisschen zu machen und
wollte dieser folge eigentlich kakteen
suchen gehen ist das dementsprechend
sehr schön dass da jetzt eine weapons
box ist mal ganz kurz wieder in die
fledermaus weil ich wollte ganz kurz
schauen wie jedoch sein zuhause da
bisher so gestaltet hat er wohnte da
ganz oben drauf was ist das der playboy
denn der hat hier oben aber nicht so
gerissen
aber das steht hier auch in jeder folge
was ist denn los mit nicht hüpfen mensch
bist du denn darf die töten oder sind
das irgendwie kumpan von kinos ich
brauche wahrscheinlich immer wieder neu
jo hat er hier überhaupt schon dir was
gemacht oder wohnte erst mal nach unten
drin war witzig wenn man sieht wie die
anderen so vorankommen das ist
wahrscheinlich ein hexenhäuschen jedoch
jedoch hier wurden wahrscheinlich geht
es ja gut ich sehr schön sehr schön da
hinten datenfunk hier weiß ich gar nicht
wer ist denn das hier
wer wohnt denn hier das führt mich sehr
interessieren wer auch stark dafür dass
ich irgendwie das wollen sich mal so
schilder dahin macht also ich meine bei
mir ist ja unverständlich aber hier
diese typen da das hier oben wollte
jetzt übrigens bei abreise er das regt
mich ja so aufwerten darum weltekel die
nase aufgebaut jedenfalls war mein plan
für diese folge eigentlich dass ich mir
diese kakteen suche und dann hier seine
weapons box kraft und an mir endlich
schusswaffen machen kann
aber anscheinend war mir da jemand
zuvorgekommen sei es vorgekommen weil
jemand sehr nett und hat diese arbeit
für mich übernommen ist natürlich sehr
sehr schön finde ich sehr schön dass das
jemand gemacht hat ich blicke jetzt mal
ganz kurz pilot fand ich sehr sehr cool
wollte ich mir daraus meine dings bauen
ein haus
horst ich kann ich nicht auskommen
keinen sinn luke soweit ich blicke jetzt
hier mal eben kommt eigentlich gar nicht
ich wollte jetzt echt eigentlich mal
relativ früh auch anfangen die kisten
schon zu sortieren
damit ich danach her nicht so unendlich
viel arbeit mit habt wisst ihr was ich
meine
zudem marsdorf ich mache mir gleich auf
jeden fall schon mal der kiste für so
ich der sache hin obwohl das ihr das
kann ich eigentlich auch schon
wegschmeißen jeder soviel diamantenabbau
ja gar nicht in rüstungs teil
dann mache ich das jetzt eben ich geh
mal ganz kurz die ich verwandeln mich
mal wieder eben kurz mich weil ich das
lieber ab wenn ich irgendwie so ein
bisschen größer bin habe ich nicht schon
voll viele kisten einmal gemacht oder er
ich glaube ich ein bisschen an
wie heißt es war wo ich mir mal so 10
milliarden kiste gemacht haben
eigentlich gar nicht gebraucht habe sie
so kisten wollte ich mir machen
dann stellen wir hier eine kiste dran
und dann mache ich mir auch so eine
gesunde richtig richtig schnieke nutzt
materialien kiste hier einfach wohl dann
so was reinkommt so was so ein mal
sondern wasser einmal muss auf jeden
fall immer dabei haben das sind so
momente die ich noch irgendwie komme ich
packe als auch bei rein oder soll ich
denn eigentlich bisher ganz essen
gelagert hier ist nur noch kohle drin
hier ist noch das noch cook das muskel
ich weiß nicht ob dieser muskel scheiße
da essen kann
warum ich überhaupt raus ich wollte hier
noch was so dass alles gebraten
strawberry seeds wollte ich ja eh alles
einfach mal alles an pflanzen hier
muskeln
ich weiß nicht was soll ich mit muskel
nicht packt erstmal diese sache rein in
das nicht mehr mit sortiert das mal eben
ganz kurz diese ganze sitz nehme ich
jetzt auch mal einfach mit coffee pauli
muskeln nicht kann ich euch ähnlich
essen schreibt mir immer in die
kommentare wenn ihr mich berichtigen
wollt dann müsst ihr nicht irgendwie
denken dass ich euch dann beginnen
sondern das wäre einfach supertoll nicht
berechtigen würde
hier kommt dann das fleisch welches
machen
wenn ich so mache ist das
jkr
ach cool stimmt da kann ich das alles so
sortieren
ja nee ich mache das jetzt aber hier mal
die ganzen hier kommt der alle reihen
gut
welche summe von hatte hier noch ein
paar materialien aber das soll keine
sortier folge werden
ich will schon noch ein bisschen was
erreichen hier so vielleicht auch nutzt
dinge also kommission mache ich mir auf
jeden fall noch eine elvis verbrennt
cobblestone wollte ich mir noch eine
kiste machen und holz halt dass stars
reinkommt dann nehme ich den ganzen korb
ist braucht ja eigentlich gar nicht
davon kann ich dann gleich jetzt mal
richtig viel wegschmeißen
hier kommt aber erst mal das ganze auch
holz rhein und die ganze kann man noch
eine kiste einfach mit cobblestone und
dort das ich dann wirklich weiß okay das
sind so sachen mit denen kann ich löcher
stopfen und soll dann ziemlich
schwachsinn werde dann braucht ihr auch
ganz gut mal ein bisschen holz hier
sollt euch alle hier kommt dann alle
mühe so kräftig cable eine auswahl an
holz ist ein bisschen unnötig das
mädchen gemacht habe oder dass den
bekommen habe dann kommt hier wo man
habe ich dann auch als palm pre konnte
ich mir keine kiste irgendwie bauen
das ging ja irgendwie nicht an dem ich
jetzt ihr euch einfach bei mir kommen
das ist so traurig sind schon wieder
sechseinhalb minuten um und ich habe
wieder nichts erreicht ich könnte weinen
freunde ich könnte echt weinen so hier
kommt rethers wobei hier kommt ihr alle
rein
das heißt dadurch jetzt einfach noch
einmal eng da muss ich darauf tut mir
stimmt ich dachte schon ganz einfachen
mitteln kisten sortiert
so und jetzt werde ich mal anfangen ich
erst mal ganz kurz wie sieht das hier
denn eigentlich will aus wenn ich das
bearbeitet habe das ist so etwas wie sie
dass intel das sieht sehr sehr hell aus
ich weiß ich hab das nicht schon zu hell
ist obwohl ich das hier stehen habe dann
geht es noch aber ich weiß nicht ob das
nicht schon zu hell ist
diese blöcke sind unglaublich schön aus
aber diese sind immer noch am schönsten
ich weiß überhaupt nicht aus welchem
material ich das machen soll hier kommt
ihr erstmal ein tolles fällt da muss ich
irgendwie durchlaufen können
ich weiß gerade überhaupt nicht hier
wollte ich überhaupt überhaupt ja noch
eine nicht ob ich mache das auch dass
ich das hier weg mache dann brauche ich
das ganze nicht schon mit diesen palmen
sachen hier voll
ich weiß dann nämlich gar nicht aus
welchem material sie mabel der zwar auch
cool aber hat ich glaube ich schon in
hero hatte ich sehr viel mal bei meinem
haus benutzt mit dem dunklen holz ich
brauche neues album habe ich das denn
her bekommen
ich glaub ich hab das ja ganz hinten
beim einbiegen die abgebauten natürlich
verwandeln ich mal ganz kurz wieder
zurück in eine feder manchmal war ich
ein paar simplen aber das war sehr sehr
weit weg
das war echt sehr sehr weit ich glaube
ich fliege zwar eben irgendwie also
erstmal hier damit die die ganzen leute
immer wissen wie macht man sich das denn
ich muss quasi nur diese dinge die ich
gebrauche in meiner in meinem inventar
habe das heisst hakan 740 brauche da
erzählen davon erzählen davon also 15
bleiben
das heißt ich gucke jetzt ich habe hier
nur fünf weisen aber den rest habe ich
selbstverständlich noch hier und kann
ich dann selbstverständlich auch eben
kurz in denen das öl einpacken dann
brauche ich ein wenig auf geburt das
kann ich mir ganz kurz beiden fällen
gehen oder unten schon bald angelegt
worden
ich weiß nicht wer da auf wo und ich
weiß nicht ob steam ist oder irgendwo
anders
wir sind ja noch meine minions nicht
dass gegenwehr mitgenommen hatte okay
hier sind viele sachen schon drin rubin
bloody in sachen nämlich einfach mit
relikt dass das teuerste stars paar
diamanten
ich weiß nicht was das bedeutet ein book
gebe eigentlich nicht und die schön da
unten jetzt noch irgendwie diesen weg
vielleicht muss ich immer wieder ruft
niemals war nicht so schwer das zu
bekommen ich hole mal eben ein bisschen
aufgebots dass ich das ganze kommen das
kann ich auch eben hier daneben
mitnehmen diese blöden stelle die
regions darum stehen
obwohl es cool aussieht mit diesen
stämmen und das ist sehr schön gemacht
1999 noch vor zehn davon jetzt das eisen
berät gerade dann kann ich mir nämlich
noch in dieser folge möchte ich folgende
mal so ein bisschen hier
ich habe gesehen dass ihr die folgen
mehr schaut wenn diese zwölf minuten
langen als wenn die irgendwie 20 minuten
lang natürlich wünscht sich über lange
folgen aber irgendwie diese statistik
bei youtube zeigen dass sie dann aktiver
mitarbeiter wenn die folgen bisschen
kürzer sind und ich bin dementsprechend
auch das kann ich für mich selbst
bezeugen produktive ab so und jetzt kann
ich nämlich zeigen wenn ich hier da drin
bin und ich gehe zwar eben hier zur ak
47 habe ich jetzt eine ak-47
das heißt ich kann dir jetzt nehmen hier
irgendwie hierfür mal reinziehen
beispielsweise jetzt habe ich eine ak
meine lieben freunde ich kann ich brauch
erst mal noch munition aber die contador
soll die munition ist auch weg war dafür
brauche ich kann paula und dieses
camcorder besitze ich nicht die
sofortige die muss ich auch mal
irgendwie ihr könnt ihr mir sagen was
sie mit den fossilien machen soll
ich packe jetzt erstmal die ganzen
sachen rein wo ich nicht verheizen
welche das kommt dann wahrscheinlich
noch eine umwelt kiste machen sind ganze
bambus sachen und sagt alles roche liegt
das ganze erstmal diese kiste wo ich
denke dass die sachen wertvoll sind muss
ich dann auch irgendwann mal alles
beraten
hiermit kann ich mir noch eine platte
machen für meinen astralen körper so
dann kann ich diese andere platte hier
wieder wegschmeißen
vielleicht doch etwas der steht ja in
jeder folge hier hier hier habe ich
eigentlich quasi nur noch ein bisschen
was sortiert ich werde jetzt in der
nächsten folge dann versuchen das ganze
hier
die stars ein bisschen palm wird mir zu
besorgen
das ist ein bisschen knapp hier ich
brauche kein pardon
ich glaub ich flieg war erst ein paar
möbel können wir uns auch mal machen wir
können ja nicht noch gucken wir können
so wir können ja eingeben
dann haben wir so ein paar dinge und
dann können wir sehen wie man sich sonst
stuhl kraft und das kann ja eben machen
damit ihr seht kommen der luca der artig
informierte das ist nicht von dover typ
natürlich auch aber die ist nicht ganz
so doof und deswegen stuhl
ich habe das falsch alte holz gut dafür
trinke ich bin eine frau die mich auch
kein mut
mensch ich mich vom feld gehen
meine damen herren vielleicht hatte
darauf den krieg und ganzen ein bisschen
ganz toller holen find ich sehr sehr
schön
23 so jetzt nebenbei das baue ich mir
eben ganz kurz den stuhl das ist echt
schön mit dieser das finde ich sehr sehr
ansprechend ich werde dir vielleicht
abbauen uns um diese weiter hier vorne
dran setzen wenn das ganze noch so ein
bisschen weiter hervor sticht quasi
so und jetzt hab ich nix und stuhl
stellt jetzt einfach mal neben kannst
auch hallo
achso kampagne im antritt so mich wie im
zurückverwandeln so jetzt bin ich wieder
ich jetzt drauf setzen
denn aufgekommen ich habe irgendein tier
auf dem kopf wie sie steht das nicht
wenn ich hier um gegen springe irgendwie
naja gut meine lieben freund ich würde
euch sagen ich gehe ganz gut kennen ich
dachte schon ich packte wiederum ich
habe ziemlich oft versuche mich darauf
zu setzen ich finde sehr schön dass mir
jemand eine weapons box gemacht hat da
werde ich mich dann nochmals herzlichst
bedanken jetzt kann ja eigentlich nur
max oder sturm waffe kann es nicht
gewesen sein
max oder kilos variante gewesen denken
berichte ich mich wenn ich falsch liege
es war eine wunderschöne folge ich hoffe
nahezu nichts erreicht aber ich habe mir
so ein bisschen gedanken darüber gemacht
ein bisschen kisten sortiert und der
nächsten folge nicht mein haus müngsten
weiter bauen beziehungsweise die nächste
folge werde ich höchstwahrscheinlich mit
paletten aufnehmen oder wer immer noch
ein bisschen quatschen bat er so machen
will was ich machen will und dann würde
ich sagen wir uns beim nächsten mal
wieder gefallen hat dann zeigt es mir
mit einem daumen nach oben
tschüss